alors que les océans se vident
l'aquaculture fournit désormais la
moitié du poids sont destinés à la
consommation humaine dans le monde mais
qui dit aquaculture dit souvent
monoculture donc une seule espèce élevé
avec parfois des impacts
environnementaux majeurs
alors comment faire autrement voici ce
que propose un fermier de la mère
originaire de terre-neuve le connecticut
un tout petit états côtiers du nord-est
des etats-unis près de la ville
portuaire de new haven le long du
détroit de longue haleine se cache un
chapelet de quelque 365 petite-ile les
il tempo dans cet archipel un nouveau
modèle l'aquaculture voit le jour et cet
homme en est le maître d'oeuvre
je cultive le milieu aquatique tout en
essayant de le restaurer je suis de
cette génération qui en cette ère de
changement climatique tentent de gagner
sa vie en redonnant vie à la mère
rinspeed fait ce qu'ils appellent de
l'aquaculture 3d un mode de production
unique sous l'eau plusieurs espèces sont
cultivés dans un même espace et se
nourrissent l'une et l'autre une
production non polluante demandé à la
mère ce qu'on devrait y produire elle
vous répondra ce qui ne nécessite aucun
intrant et nous on utilise un engrais ni
eau potable
c'est l'une des cultures les plus
durables sur la planète
[Musique]
américain d'adoption brent butt est
originaire de terre-neuve jeunes
pêcheurs canadiens il connaît les belles
années de la pêche à la morue et
travaille sur les navires usines les
plus performants mais il voit aussi les
stocks de morue s'effondrer soulevant la
colère des pêcheurs
conscient des effets dévastateurs de la
surpêche sur le milieu marin
il change de cap et part travailler dans
les fermes d'élevage de saumons
j'ai travaillé dans les fermes d'élevage
de saumons dans le nord canadien
ce devait être une solution à la
surpêche créer des emplois en
nourrissant la planète mais c'était
plutôt une production industrielle
polluante avec des ch'ti si
d'antibiotiques une véritable porcherie
géante en plein air
désillusionnés perdu je me suis retrouvé
dans les ultimes beau et je suis devenu
producteur d'huîtres en histoire on
itunes de rédemption écologique sera
ostréiculteurs pendant sept ans et le
malheur frappe deux fois plutôt qu'une
l'ouragan irène en 2011
puis samedi l'année suivante détruisent
90% de sa production
ce coup dur le force à repenser son
modèle d'aquaculture à faire les choses
autrement
[Musique]
ça a été un point tournant les tempêtes
le réchauffement de l'eau c'était des
signes avant-coureurs de crise
climatique
alors je me suis relevé et je me suis
réinventer comme fermier de la mer avec
ma ferme verticale trois dimensions je
me sers de toute la colonne d'eau
l'installation est à l'épreuve des
ouragans et je cultive plusieurs espèces
ce qui crée des récifs artificiels qui
résistent mieux aux changements
climatiques et les athéniens
[Musique]
guen et son assistante ont prévu faire
aujourd'hui leur première récolte des
huîtres de la saison
la brise matinale est fraîche et douce
le bateau vogue sur une mer d'huile
[Musique]
le site de production est près de la
côte vue de la surface de l'eau il
paraît bien modeste
lapointe culteurs d'ethier de bail de
location qui lui permet d'exploiter
cette propriété publique marie
ces activités de pêche n'interfère pas
avec les activités de plaisance
soit on peut nager pêcher ici
le site ne nous appartient pas on a un
permis pour la culture de coquillages et
d'agde ont créé des parcs marins on
protège le bien commun c'est
l'aquaculture de l'avenir ces espaces
communautaires l'aquaculture 3d est un
véritable échafaudage sous marins
d'abord à la surface de l'eau se trouve
la corde qui sert de support de
croissance aux alpes puis dans le milieu
de la colonne d'eau sont suspendus à des
cordes d'élevage de moules et des
paniers de pétanque
enfin sur le fond marin reposent les
poches d'huîtres et les caisses de
palourdes ces techniques d'élevage
malgré sa forte densité imite en quelque
sorte l'écosystème marin naturel les
moules les huîtres et les pétoncles se
nourrissent de nutriments et joue en
quelque sorte le rôle de filtre naturel
les algues elles absorbent les polluants
produit par les autres espèces cultivées
le moment est venu de sortir les poches
d'huîtres pour avoir un aperçu de la
récolte à venir
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est une des huit on voit la branche
ea ces petits coquillages qui ont grandi
en mer pendant quelques années ont des
vertus étonnantes les autres filtres la
zot une seule huîtres pu filtrer 50
gallons d'eau par jour sur le site de la
ferme des millions de gallons douce ont
filtré chaque semaine c'est une arme
secrète de mère nature pour équilibrer
l'écosystème alors en produisant 18 ans
redonne vie au milieu moeurs
rinspeed doit maintenant relever les
cordes d'algues pour vérifier
l'avancement de la culture
éventuellement ces petites halde
formeront une vaste forêt sous marine
qui servira de pouponnière et de
garde-manger pour plusieurs espèces
sézanne ont un autre atout écologique
elle absorbe et séquestrent la zone le
phosphore est aussi le dioxyde de
carbone on l'appelle le séquoia des
mères l'algue absorbe cinq fois plus de
carbone qu'une plantes terrestres
alors on dit qu'on est fermier du climat
ont séquestrer le carbone et ont nourri
la communauté les zincs grandissent à
une vitesse fulgurante
elles peuvent croître de plus de 1 m par
année
elles servent d'engrais pour
l'agriculture locale
mais brent smith les vend surtout qu'en
produits alimentaires
il a même aménagé un centre de
transformation dans le maine où il
développe ses propres plats à base
d'algues des nouilles par exemple c'est
le légume de l'avenir on adore cet album
ou sucrés cette plante indigène à la
belle couleurs translucides
c'est très délicat
[Musique]
les algues entre déjà dans la
composition de plusieurs aliments crème
glacée yo gourd bonbons sauce mayonnaise
et certains plats préparés
et des chercheurs croient qu'elles
pourraient également servir à nourrir
les animaux d'élevage
à quelques reprises durant la semaine
brent smith se déplace lui même pour
faire des livraisons dans des commerces
de la région de new haven
la récolte aujourd'hui est destiné à un
restaurant renommé
[Musique]
abed rabbo
chef propriétaire est un fidèle client
qui apprécie particulièrement les
produits locaux
il aime ajouter des touches d'algues à
certains de ses plats ils cuisinent des
halles de fermenter par exemple c'est un
produit très polyvalent cuisine plus je
travaille avec les algues plus je le
constate à cette production locale
consommer sur place cette notion de
proximité sont au coeur de la
philosophie de brent smith et de son
modèle d'aquaculture qu'il souhaite voir
se multiplier
on peut vraiment nourrir la planète en
aménageant de fermes dans une zone
grande comme l'état de washington
on pourrait techniquement nourrir le
monde produire des aliments sans eau
potable ni engrais c'est la parfaite
cuisine climatique
[Musique]
une nouvelle génération de fermiers de
la mer voit d'ailleurs le jour green
wave une organisation mise sur pied par
brent smith en forme et accompagne des
aquaculteurs qui adhèrent à ce modèle
basé sur le développement durable
plusieurs fermes marines 3d sont
maintenant en opération non seulement
sur la côte est américaine mais aussi en
alaska en californie et aux îles féroé
avec une modeste écloserie comme celle
ci il est possible de se lancer dans
l'aventuré
le concept de l'écloserie simple et peu
coûteux on veut un modèle reproductible
avec 50000 dollars on peut construire
une écloserie dans un conteneur pour
alimenter 25 fermes
on peut installer ça n'importe où au
québec et ailleurs grossir à l'aide de
son communautaires locaux
[Musique]
d'ailleurs brentwood croit que son
modèle de fermes marines peut aisément
s'adapter à un milieu aquatique froid et
couverts de glace pendant quelques mois
comme au québec
[Musique]
pour ce visionnaire ancien pêcheur
converti à l'aquaculture durable et les
grand temps d'agir de réinventer le rôle
du pêcheur et de repenser l'économie de
la pêche
bref de former encore davantage de
fermiers de la mer
[Musique]
je ne suis qu'un pion dans tout ça mais
je représente des milliers de gens qui
suivent cette année on fait les choses
autrement et tous ensemble on fait
partie de la solution
c'est emballant
[Musique]